عاكسة مودي مثل العديد من المراهقين ،
اعتبرت نيكا شكارامي صفحتها على Instagram
مساحة آمنة للتعبير عن الذات ،
لكن وفاتها في 20 سبتمبر أثناء
الاحتجاجات في إيران حولتها إلى
أيقونة وصفحتها على Instagram إلى صفحة فارغة مما أدى إلى
تعطيلها ولماذا أصبح
لغزًا آخر  المحيطة بما
حدث لها سي إن إن كشفت سابقًا عن
أدلة تشير إلى أن نيكا احتُجزت
في الاحتجاجات بعد وقت قصير
من تصوير هذا الفيديو ، لكن السلطات
الإيرانية نفت دائمًا أي تورط في
اختفائها أو وفاتها الآن يمكن لـ CNN أن
تكشف حصريًا أن الشركة الأم لـ meta Instagram
حققت في
حساب Nika بعد  اختفت لتخلص إلى
أنهم أنفسهم لم يشاركوا في
تعطيلها ، بمعنى آخر ،
إما أن نيكا نفسها أو شخصًا
لديه حق الوصول إلى حسابها هو الذي قام
بإزالته ، وبما أن التقارير الأخيرة التي نشرتها The
Intercept كشفت عن نظام إيران المتطور للغاية
لاختراق الهاتف ،
فإنه يثير السؤال.  ما إذا كانت
منصة وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي و  يمكن أن تحافظ Orms على
أمان الحسابات عندما اندلعت الاحتجاجات في إيران
بدأت Nica في استخدام Instagram كمذكرات
لنشاطها ، لكن هذا النشاط عبر الإنترنت
ربما انتهى به الأمر
ضدها
بعد وفاة Nika ، حيث بدأت الدولة الإيرانية
في نشر أدلة مثل لقطات CCTV هذه في
محاولة لتطهير حالة
أي تورط في وفاتها أولاً
قالوا إنها دفعت من هذا المبنى
ثم سقطت منه بعد ذلك ،
وأشاروا إلى رسائل انتحارية في
المستندات المستخرجة من محادثات Nika على الهاتف المحمول
و Instagram ، لقد كان
اعترافًا مفتوحًا بأنهم كانوا يصلون إلى
هاتفها وحساباتها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
.  ليست وحدها
حيث اجتاحت النيران سجن إيفان سيئ السمعة
في منتصف أكتوبر
، فقد اتُهمت ناجين بمشاركة
ملصقات ناشطة مثل هذه على برقية
منصة التواصل الاجتماعي المشفرة ، لقد
غيرنا اسمها حفاظًا على سلامتها
، قرأ ممثل على ما أعتقد كلماتها  لقد
أجروا بالفعل دردشات التلغرام الخاصة بي
لأنهم غالبًا ما تحدثوا عنها ، وكانت هناك
بعض الصور التي أستخدمها  شارك الإعلان
صورًا سياسية نسبيًا كانوا يعرضون لي
الصور من تلك البرقية للادعاء بأنني
كنت المشرف ولكني ظللت أنكر ذلك وتقول إن
السلطات الإيرانية حصلت على
هذه المحادثات على الرغم من عدم وجود
هاتف nagin حتى الآن ، فهي تعتقد أنهم اخترقوا
حسابها وهي تواجه الآن  ست سنوات
في السجن
أثناء وجودها في السجن ، أعادت السلطات الإيرانية
تنشيط حساب تلغرام نادين الذي
تقول إنه كان لمعرفة من حاول
الاتصال بها والكشف عن شبكة
النشطاء التي كانت على اتصال بها ،
وربما تم استخدام نفس التكتيك مع
حساب برقية نيكا لأسابيع.  بعد
وفاتها ، لاحظ اثنان من أصدقائها أن
حسابها قد عاد إلى الإنترنت ، فقد اختفى
بعد فترة وجيزة
من وفاة عائلة نيكا التي لا تزال تعاني من
وفاتها ، أخبر أحد أفراد العائلة المقربين CNN أن
السلطات لا تزال ترفض إعادة
هاتفها ، وأن السلطات الإيرانية
لم ترد على مكالمات CNN.  طلب
للتعليق بينما قال ماتا إنهم لا يستطيعون
مشاركة تفاصيل حساب نيكا
لكنهم أكدوا أنهم لم يفعلوا ذلك  أخيرًا ، قم
بتعطيله برقية لـ CNN في كل
حالة قاموا بالتحقيق في
مصادرة الجهاز أو جعل المستخدم
هذا الوصول ممكنًا عن غير قصد من خلال
عدم تعيين كلمة مرور للتحقق من خطوتين
أو استخدام تطبيق ضار في تخصيص
Telegram ،
لا تزال هناك أسئلة حول ما إذا كانت
meta  تبذل Telegram وشركات التكنولوجيا الأخرى
كل ما في وسعها لحماية
مستخدميها بينما يستيقظ العالم على
الأساليب التي تزداد فيها المعرفة بالتكنولوجيا التي
تستخدمها أنظمة مثل إيران لمراقبة
وتعقب الناشطين
كاتي بوغل سي إن إن لندن